Trump right now is up Five Points over
Biden nationally according to a a
messenger Harris poll this is going to
increase the pressure to get Joe Biden
out of the race by the Democrats because
we sometimes think that the Democrats
are so powerful they control all of the
institutions the academy the media the
administrative government the big Tech
the corporation they control all of the
institutions increasingly the military
but they're not omnipotent
they're not God
I think they can still lose elections
they lost in 2016 when we were told that
was going to be impossible I think that
can still happen if their candidate is
sufficiently bad and our candidate is
sufficiently smart I think we can win